what up space fam golden here from anime
uproar back at it again to discuss the
latest developments in the one piece
story
and we've been waiting for this
development for a long time so make sure
to stay tuned for this one if you enjoy
these one-piece reviews i want to keep
them coming then channel the pirate king
within and smash that like button with
no mercy
if you haven't joined the nakama right
now by hitting that subscribe button
and most importantly hit that
notification bell or you will miss
future one piece videos
and while you wait for the next intense
chapter to drop feel free to check out
my growing one piece playlist where i
got videos about the yonko warlord
supernova and more
link to that is in the description now
without further ado let's jump into it
this chapter is called the night
reflected on a go board
and i actually did watch a documentary
recently about go and how ai
has gotten to the point where it can
beat the masters so i will actually be
able to understand this reference
not gonna lie though it did make me a
bit sad that computers surpassed humans
in this game i was definitely rooting
for the humans
but back to the chapter and it can't
start out any more hype than this
we're told that luffy is attacking with
every fiber of his being he's hitting
kaido everywhere and kaido's just taking
it
big mom is shocked by the scene as his
kid when luffy sends kaido's dragon form
down to the ground
with one final punch big mom is
wondering and asking for kaido as if
checking if he's still
conscious so this is some crazy stuff
doing something like this to the
strongest creature in the world and
shocking another yonko in the process is
no joke
luffy has come a long way however this
insane strength comes at a price
and luffy becomes powerless after
prolonged use of his fourth gear kid is
shocked wondering when he got hit and la
explains that he didn't it's just a side
effect
of that power and that he'll be unable
to use hockey for 10 minutes
to kid it makes sense that such a power
has drawbacks but it's still worth it if
those blows did some damage
but with kaido it really seems like he
just shrugs off everything no matter how
cool or devastating the attacks look
at this point no matter how an attack
looks i'm just assuming kaido is fine
until we see otherwise big mom takes
advantage of luffy's weakness and moves
in for the kill and zorro has to jump in
and save luffy's limp body
now the luffy is going to be out for a
bit we can expect zoro law and kid
to shine some more since luffy was
definitely hogging the spotlight there
maybe kill her too but he's already
shown us something we're still waiting
on you
kid to blow us away just want to note
that i really like this kind of fighting
and storytelling i like that luffy
despite how strong he is still needs to
depend on others to win this fight
whether they win or lose it's gonna be a
team effort and now back to kid even
though he didn't blow us away yet
he tells killer to not let up because
they're going to finish kaido off you
love to see it even though you know
it's a woefully premature statement
kaido uses the move dragon twister and
he just keeps looking more and more like
a pokemon doesn't he
long story short kid and killer are
blown away by this attack as most people
are
zorro mentions that it really is like
facing a natural disaster and like i
mentioned in the previous chapters i
love all of these godlike comparisons to
the forces of nature
they are hyping up the yonko so much
that it's going to be so satisfying if
our mere humans
who we watch grow up manage to come out
on top zoro loses hold of luffy he is
about to get swallowed by kaido
when zorro has one of his sick what do
you think you're doing with my captain
moment
as zoro uses three sword style kaido
affirms
that it is a sword that is the source of
the strange haki
how the significance of the sword will
play out let me know what you think but
we cannot underestimate zoro's role in
all of this
an op sword needs an op wielder to bring
out its potential
and it's so sick to see zorro form the
shape of a dragon to attack a dragon he
uses great dragon twister to actually
penetrate
kaido's scales and the name of this move
is absolutely
perfect as if there weren't enough
reasons that zoro should be the one to
take on a main role in taking kaido down
even big mom is surprised that zoro
actually cut kaido
again she singles out zorro not just the
sword luffy and
zoro have both been absolutely amazing
so far in this fight in my view the
others really gotta pick up the slack
kaido finally figures out that it's
odin's sword that zorro is using as
you'd expect kaido is not seriously hurt
and he laughs off the idea that his
twister could be countered by another
one
he uses dragon twister guild destruction
and sends air blades flying at everyone
law has the easiest time avoiding it but
zoro is struggling to get luffy and him
out of the way
and unfortunately we now move away from
the roof but you gotta admit oda gave us
more uninterrupted on-the-roof content
than we probably expected people
mentioned that the roof fight must be
insane as debris keeps raining down
we see orochi's head again making us
think he may yet be alive
as a result of his mythical 8 headed
snake devil fruit honestly i'll be very
surprised if he doesn't survive at this
point
it's a mythical zone called heavy heavy
no me model
yamata no orochi and we all know how
many times
orochimaru from naruto came back cp 0
the strongest of all cypher pole units
is actually present they're playing go
and they mention being invited to the
feast
i love it when we see these big players
get involved there are some interesting
convo
topics like the clash between kaido and
the worst generation being inevitable
after doflamingo's defeat the man says
it seems like
fate conspired to make allies of samurai
and the pirates
so this is yet another mention of fate
where yamato actually recently mentioned
fate
2 fate really does seem to play a big
role in one piece
you could say that luffy is fated to be
the pirate king when you see all the
parallels he has with goal d
roger it's mentioned that the world is
about to undergo a drastic shift
and that if two emperors were to fall
the future would become uncertain that's
clear enough to us without them having
to say it
but it does raise the significance of
this battle even more it's said that the
emperor's failing is an impossible
outcome but this wouldn't be the first
time that luffy made the seemingly
impossible happen
we're told the invaders definitely lost
less men but they had less to begin with
our boys are complimented for the
surprise raid as a strategy but it's
mentioned that simply assassinating the
enemy's leadership
is unlikely to settle the conflict
interesting words and part of that is
also because there are so many big
players present
five supernova on the roof and two yonko
not counting all the other big names
here
it makes sense that if a captain was
taken down such strong fighters
would go for revenge rather than giving
up for these reasons
they feel like countering kaido's
executives will be ki
or like a go board they'll be surrounded
with no way out
this is a nice nod to the importance of
the other battles going on which may not
be as hyped as the main one
but are nonetheless significant again
everyone's role is vital and you gotta
love that about one piece
what frankie sanji nami usop and the
rest do
even if they're not as strong as luffy
is still very
very important and cp 0 end up seeming
like the only winners here
since they want the pirates to take each
other out as much as possible so there's
a third party getting to capitalize on
the fighting of the other two i feel
like i'm playing risk all over again and
if there's one thing you should know
about risk it's to pay attention to the
guy fortifying in australia while the
others fight amongst themselves
this is a nice perspective shift showing
that even if they somehow managed to
beat the yonko which
already sounds impossible they'll be
weak enough so another force can step in
and finish them off
let's just hope shanks cruises in at the
last second again
and then there's the moment of truth as
law mentions
kaido finally takes on his hybrid form
we've been waiting for this for so long
and this tells me we're going to see
kaido more serious than we've ever seen
him before
on one end it's a compliment for our
guys pushing him to this point and on
the other end it looks really bad for
our dudes
after all the damage luffy and zorro and
the others gave kaido
he just laughs and says this is getting
fun big mom says she was thinking the
same thing
and we're told the mighty emperors
blocked their path and it looks
like there will be no break next week so
let's get hyped for seeing kaido's
hybrid form next chapter
for although we do get the sense of it
in this one oda is a hype master
and he knows that keeping the form in
the shadows for now
is the way to build that juicy hype for
the next chapter but yeah despite
everything we've seen so far
kaido is just laughing and doesn't seem
to be too worried
and doesn't seem like he was taking it
seriously i feel like we're going to
need blackbeard and moria to get in here
soon because
these guys just don't seem like they'll
be able to pull it off alone right now
the accomplishments of the supernova
have been very commendable so far but
let's be real the yonko are just getting
started and luffy is out of commission
for 10 minutes
but man this is so hype i can't wait to
see what happens next
let me know your predictions in the
comments and what you thought of this
chapter if you do enjoy seeing these
one-piece chapter reviews they want to
keep them coming channel your inner
pyroking and smash that like button with
no mercy if you haven't joined the
nakama right now by hitting that
subscribe button and most importantly
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future one piece videos and while
you wait for the next intense chapter to
drop
feel free to check out my growing one
piece playlist where i have videos about
the yonko
warlords supernova and much more link to
that is in the description
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one
possible first and foremost i want to
thank the patron of legend the one
acknowledged by lord tuigo himself
and the most donated champion of the
world alpha sigma
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans in grotta the
world acquire respect pate heffa
liam thompson al-jatal dr cortman
johnny boy draws emperor otaku spidey
life tinel baked buddhist and tungsten
tarkis
and our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh steelers angel cruz
anatoly kazatsuki joe stanton very gucci
jessica kayla fawn rathu and aora alicia
actor bonnie parks hinokami and water
the red haired raven joanne garcia jack
watches anime fat boy games deadly saint
matthew cruz
and anthony schreiber thank you all so
much if you enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as low as one dollar if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos alongside these
epic people right here and you'll even
get access to our private patron only
discord where we talk about anime life
and of course
dank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description
if you're interested you can also join
the youtube channel by clicking that
blue join button next to the subscribe
button that you've hopefully
already destroyed so yeah you can
support work on that way if you prefer
and whichever way you choose to support
us you can get the same
great benefits thanks again and until
next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you